Hello Everybody.
My name is Markiplier, and uh
Ignore my face, I was getting emotional
I was spending, uh, my evening doing my normal activity
Of crying gratuitously
Um
But, in all seriousness, I am going to be unapologetically emotional in this video
So if that is not to your tastes, then
Buckle up, it's about to get teary-eyed in here
Um, and I know this is a weird video to post after I just kinda, like-
Threw everyone for a loop with that last video
I, uh-
And, and...
I realized, after I posted that one
That
I've never been happier to make videos
Which is weird, considering I am saying I'm- I'm extremely emotional
But, yknow
If there's one thing that I am, it's always open and honest with how I feel at any given moment, and
And
The way I feel
In terms of making videos, and the way I feel in terms of talking with you guys
Y'know, that's changed and evolved over time, but the one thing that
I've always stayed true to, or at least I've always tried to, is
Y'know
What this means to me
I mean, y'know, I haven't gotten emotional in a video since probably, like
Close to the 8 Million Subscriber Milestone video, and
And after I posted that video- Cause I was thinking of, yknow
I was sitting around my house and I was just like, "Ah, what am I gonna make today?"
And then I shot it, I edited it, and
I posted it, and I was watching all the reactions that was just like constant screaming like
"Agh, not again! I'm not even over Who Killed Markiplier! Oh God, you can't do this to me!"
And, I love that
I loved it; Not because I was messing with people, but because there was
There was, like, real emotions out of it, y'know?
Because, after I posted that and I was walking around my house
I was thinking out the story of where it was gonna go, and I was like
"Oh man, if I- After I post that one, I could do this and this and this
And, y'know, I can make this other story" And then, I started thinking about
Everything that I've made
Up until this point in the six years that I've been making videos, and I've been
I was thinking about
Y'know, where I've come from and the road
That
That took me to this point in my life where I'm able to make whatever I want
And even when I'm not 100% happy with what I'm making, you guys are so understanding that you give me the opportunity
To take a break
And to step back, and then come back at it harder than ever before
And
And I remember every day that I made videos
I remember every single video that I've ever made
I remember the people that I've met on this journey, I remember the people that I've lost
And everything- Every single moment in my mind
Coming to this point where I am
Where I'm so lucky to be in a position where you guys look up- Where you guys look up to me with
Hope, and
You look to me for guidance
And I try my best to be able to provide that to you, and I try my best to
Provide entertainment to you, and I try my best
And this weird ride that I've been on, especially this past year
This past year has been such an emotional
Like, growing point for me
And again, I'm not crying because I'm sad. I don't want anyone to ever think that
It may be sad memories that happened in my life, but I don't regret a single one of them
Like, past mistakes and everything that's led to this point, those
Those moments made me who I am today
And they're gonna make me who I am in the future, and
And if anything, like
The one thing that always gets me
Is, I remember the person that I was before I started doing YouTube
And before I started forging my own path
And before you guys started believing in me
And, I remember
I remember that the one thing, the only thing that I wanted
And I didn't expect anything else to come out from it, but the one thing that I always wanted
Was, I wanted to be proud of myself
And I never expected that millions of others would be proud of me too, y'know?
That is, by far
The greatest gift I've ever been given in my life
Because I don't know where I'm going, y'know?
No one does
Everyone who has ever lived is flying by the seat of their pants
And we're all doing fine
You're doing fine, I'm doing fine; I'm doing more than fine
I know it doesn't seem like it right now with tears and snot running down my face, but I am
So unbelievably grateful, and so unbelievably happy
To be where I am, and to see how far I've come
Because
Like I said, I remember every moment in my journey to get to this point
I remember every single thing
Every video I've done, every feeling that's caused, every person I've met
Every life I've impacted in one way or another
It isn't about the specific things that I do in my videos, it's about the fact that we can all take a moment and take a breather
And we can enjoy a silly moment together
And we can love something for the sake of loving something, and not because of what it's done, y'know?
We can explore the u- Y'know, we can explore the unknown together and we can be afraid, and we can be vulnerable and we can be open
And that's fine
And we can take the time to discover who we need to be
Yknow, people will constantly criticize you no matter where you go, and people will constantly try to break you down, and it does not matter
Because no one can know you more than you
I can't even know you
I want to know you
If there's one thing that I know
It's how I want to feel so much more
Than what we see through the screen
And, y'know, I joke about it sometimes
I do
And it's all in good fun, but I always realize how serious
Like, the statements that people make, y'know
How people say that I saved their life, y'know
I don't take that lightly
Because, I've seen that in the eyes of kids I've met through the Make A Wish Foundation
I've seen that through the people that I've met at conventions
I've seen it
On the internet, I've seen it on messageboards, I've seen it in the gifts that people give me
Not tangible gifts, but like- Real, emotional gifts
Cause I don't place value in things, I place value in people
And I joke about me getting emotional on camera, I don't care
Because it's true
And it's honest
The only thing I've ever wanted to be is proud of myself
And I
I can never thank you guys enough
Ah god, I've been rambling for a while
My point, eugh
My point is, I get emotional
And I'm open and honest with you guys
Because that's what matters
The connection that we have
The connection that the community has, the connection that we instill in others
And, this journey that we're taking together and where it's gonna lead next, I have no idea
I have no idea where it's gonna go next
But I can't wait
I can't wait for the next video
I can't wait for the next adventure, I cannot wait
To see what we're gonna make next
So, thank you everybody so much for watching
Again, sorry for the late night upload and sorry for the scare, uh
Unfortunately, there's more on the way because I've got a plan and it's
It's probably gonna change mid-plan fifteen times, but
I can't wait
This is the greatest gift any person could ever ask for
Despite all the pain, despite all the hard work, despite all the struggle and the internal, like, learning of myself
I'm grateful for every step that I've been able to take, and I'm so glad that you guys are here with me
And just know that if an idiot like me can go from being the least confident person, who never speaks out for himself
To who you see in front of you
Which may or may not be an improvement, depending on your metrics, but- If I can do it
You can
So thank you everybody so much for watching
And as always, I will see you in the next video
Buh-bye!
Bye!
Bye guys
Bye